you
I'm it I'm gonna be talking about
graphing here with angular SVG and d3
here's me my info I not actually really
very active on like Twitter or like
socially on github but you know even
that's that's why if your cool it's
actually uh I don't know why I put this
slide in but actually I just wanted to
ask people if there actually are people
actually familiar with SVG and yeah kind
of show of hands
SVG kind of d3 people awesome
we're gonna get into some some details
there cool so SVG I'm gonna sort of fly
through some of this stuff because my
talk was running long even in a little
practice earlier today so I'm gonna try
to just speed through we can talk about
stuff where people have questions so SVG
great things about it it's dumb right so
as opposed to canvas you draw things and
they're actually still things in the Dom
right Candice you draw things and
they're just like in a grid of pixels
and you can't change colors you can't do
anything without redrawing into the
canvas right so with dumb stuff you can
select and modify different pieces of it
there are elements they have a lot of
the same sort of scriptable properties
and style properties as HTML elements
that can capture events so you want to
attach Mouse handlers onto specific
shapes in your SVG you can style them
with CSS I think I mentioned already um
so you can change colors you can
actually have a designer actually work
on stuff instead of writing code to
change colors so here's just a little
example that it's kind of stupid
examples
here's the piece of the chart has a line
in it so we have the stroke color
they're designer can come through you
change the color and it actually changes
in the thing so yay cool you can also
change things you can change fonts of
speaking text elements you can change
opacity you can use things like hover
States to change things when the mouse
goes over you can use CSS transitions to
move things around so it's very familiar
to people that develop with HTML as
front-end developers do so I'm not
really going to compare it too much the
canvas is just what we were using before
because I think thick we mostly know
what the advantages are especially
resolution independence which is really
cool infinite zoom you can print it and
it looks amazing at a poster size very
cool you can also export so they're
actually just standalone SVG files you
can grab stuff from the inspector in
chrome and it's like copy as HTML paste
it into a file and that's like an image
file just very cool cool so next up I'm
just going to talk briefly about d3 most
people know what d3 is it's stands for
data-driven documents so it's a very
popular framework right now for
visualizations Dom manipulation in
particular
SVG manipulation so here's some pros so
we've created by some really really
smart guys with PhDs like Stanford's
visualization lab and then at the New
York Times so it has a very solid
backbone you know it's not some cruddy
piece of papers it knows how to do
things with SVG which is really cool
because you probably know how to do
things with SVG too it's just like HTML
or whatever right you can write it by
hand which is really cool but you know
certain parts of it you probably don't
want to write by hand
like here's a line right that has a D
attribute that's just that what
so it also d3 also knows there do other
things effects we do that are really
cool right you can it can draw axes out
of like multiple SVG components and pick
nice values to take things off it it can
animate things around it has like
nonlinear scaling functions for your
logarithmic graphs and stuff
it has pluggable layouts that are really
awesome if you've seen some demos of
like force-directed layouts where you
grab nodes and move them and everything
else like that's dragged around with it
and reconfigures very cool stuff it's
extremely modular and flexible so broken
down into really small pieces that you
can use just by themselves without using
the rest of the framework which is
really cool
the API is like really well done lots of
lots of the functions tape optional
other functions that you can pass to
them to sort of reconfigure how it's
gonna access your data or do things like
that which is really cool there's also a
super active community with lots of
impressive examples if you visited the
home page you've seen that if you
haven't you should definitely check out
the home page which i think is d3.js
you'll find it yeah super cool examples
you probably if you ever look at a head
Packer news or something you've probably
seen cool examples like - there was like
an awesome Obama's 2012 budget thing
that was in New York Times well New York
Times uses it all the time that was just
super awesome with like little bubbles
floating around showing size of
different federal budget allocations and
you could click and sort of reorganize
them in different ways so some kinds of
d3 right so it's not it's not everything
is not great it's extremely modular and
flexible so it's it has this like
sprawling API that is pretty
intimidating at first it was created by
really really smart guys in PHP so again
like the API is like you know you can go
through several tutorials and still kind
of not really understand what you're
doing which it's just it's kind of hard
to do simple things right so you have
all these components like I mentioned
axes and scales and you know can draw
that line path and stuff but there's no
like line graph component right I'm sure
someone's written one but like d3 itself
is is pretty low level stuff so to do
anything substantial with it you kind of
have to do a lot of boilerplate so when
we're moving to angular I'd already been
messing around with d3 a little bit in
our old closure code base and it's sort
of you know come up with some ideas for
things you know we kind of know at this
point in our in the life of the company
we're 5 years old that like you know we
do certain things all the time we do bar
graphs we do line graphs a lot right so
I knew we sort of needed something that
was going to be reused a lot this is
something that definitely it's worth it
so we took the shark beat plus angular
plus v3 and created a library called c3
and some design goals in mind so first
up we wanted to handle the common cases
like I just mentioned right like line
charts bar charts that sort of stuff we
wanted to handle those with a lot of
ease right we do those all the time so
not much boilerplate we wanted to really
lower the learning curve so that you
know that didn't have to be like a
couple experts at the company that knew
how to use this thing and that you know
it would be really easy for people to
just quickly prototype things right
because lots of times our designs are I
mean our designs are in flux right they
sort of gradually develop as we're
developing products so you don't want to
have to spend forever making some sort
of graph just to see like once you've
got some client data into that thing in
a final design that like it's on every
client you look for like the line is
just like a flat line that doesn't tell
them anything right so we use this for
prototyping all the time so we wanted
allow for designers of style which is
pretty trivial when you're using SVG
you know with some sort of smart
attachment of classes on things or
whatever it makes it makes it pretty
good so we wanted to follow angular
idioms and in particular that means that
we want to be able to declaratively
create these graphs using templates
right so if you want to add a line and
another line and axes that shows dates
or something like these things can all
be in your template right they're sort
of visual things it makes it easier for
the designers to go into the actual
template files and see like how the
graph is constructed so they can do
styles up we want to use angular data
binding right this is one of the killer
features of angular right is you create
these templates you put in your little
double curly bracket things and
interpolates values you give certain
directives like expressions and that was
just get evaluated all the time and it
figures it out and draw those things so
we want that to happen and ideally we
want it to play well with existing
directives so things like ng show and do
repeat ng click we want those to just
sort of work on the graphs and finally
we want to allow for composability
so you know we don't just want to create
and this sort of goes into what we're
talking about about the reusable
components and sort of breaking things
down into smaller pieces is we don't
want to just create like a line graph
component that then you have to add like
a million attributes to that thing to
tell it what to do we wanted to sort of
build smaller pieces and then allow us
to compose them within the template
so so we have these technologies we have
angular we have d3 we have SVG
how do we actually get them to all work
together what's the best approach so the
sort of most obvious thing if you're
coming from an angular might first you
might first think let's take an angular
centric approach
I'll just put SVG in my template right I
can just create an SVG and put it right
in my template and it'll appear on the
page no problem I can use v3 in my
controller to take the data from my
model so my domain did I mean you know
my client data or business day or
whatever and transform it into a
presentation model so I can run it
through d3s line functions to actually
produce that gigantic string that
actually told that line what to draw
right so I could just do that on my
controller and then put that sort of
presentation model that string on my
scope and let the template render it
into the SVG so does this actually work
so here's a simple example here I've
defined a controller I just held my
little code text place of playground so
we've got the playground control here
that has a model with just an array of a
few a few numbers on here and then here
in my template I'm using that controller
here right so that stuff is set up on
the scope within here for I create an
SVG and then in here I'm repeating both
of these things right so I'm ng
repeating this SVG circle for each item
in this test array and I'm using ng
attribute if you're not familiar it's
like ng HRF you basically if you just
try to assign this as the exit it will
throw an error but there's that value
does not valid until actually angular
puts an actual number in there
so basically we're templating in the
value that we're repeating on right so
this has been repeat same thing with the
right so then high-five that actually
worked
right so rnd repeats works everything
works fine we've got circles we got
rectangles squares so we're gonna reuse
this all the time in our products
I predict right this is the designers
are creating a circle squares I'm
creating it directly right so I'm gonna
capsulate this template that I just used
in here like why do I need to end you
repeat both of those things when I could
create one directive and then just send
you repeat that thing that's all
encapsulated right so I create a custom
X doesn't really work as like a
attribute thing that you can set because
angular will pull the X out if you know
how it changes so I'm gonna call the
attribute that they have to set on the
directive CDX
and we'll find that to our isolate so
the X and then each of these things uses
that next to drop right
the chocolate instead of having the
actual less needy stuff in here now now
I just have my directive I'm repeating
that I found this thing to that CVX so
that gets bound to X within the
directive and it should all draw finally
okay so this is actually what we get
nothing nothing happens and if you
actually if you look in the demo you'll
kind of see everything there it looks
like it should work right the SVG is
here here's your thing here's the circle
on the Rex but this actually doesn't
work because this thing is not an SVG
thing right like you created this thing
in html5 it's fine to have these unknown
elements that have a name that the
parser doesn't understand really but for
SVG it doesn't right so it has no idea
what to do this is this even though your
circle and Rex like looked like valid
SVG and everything that's just not
actually going to work so let's try this
again instead of having a directed
element will have to directly be an
attribute right so everything else is
the same here it's just gonna be a
little bit different the way that we use
this directive so here in our template
now instead of the CV Circle Square of
being an element we're using an SVG
element which is just like a generic
group right it doesn't really do
anything unless you set like a transform
on earth or hide it or something it just
groups other anyways so now this is a
valid scg element this is just sort of
unknown attribute on that element that
that should be fine so yeah it works
again we got our circle squares everyone
in chrome land is happy in Firefox land
there's nothing and we actually inspect
this in Firefox as inspector then you'll
find if you dig in and here I'm going to
select I selected the circle in the
inspector and then in the console here
I'm going to inspect the namespace of
that circle and it's actually somehow
Firefox got confused and in the course
of rendering like angular's rendering
engine taking that template and turning
it into these things it ended up as an
HTML on it so now we have sort of this
other problem where now our geo moment
doesn't
but now the stuff inside is in Firefox
at least is this is not an SVG circle
it says circle it's an HTML unknown
element called circle and so that's sort
of an issue with with using this sort of
approach um so so it works for simple
cases right we we got it working fine
right like we could have done cool
advantage of that and we could sort of
stretch and do maybe a lot cooler things
with that but like we probably always be
dancing around these problems we're like
we're never quite sure if like our
directives our templates are gonna
render correctly you're like an angular
they change like one little thing in the
library like maybe the rendering engine
which uses innerhtml for a lot of this
stuff which is why I like a lot of these
things don't really work very well
including like transclusion if you try
to transclude like little parts of SVG
and you're not like exactly in the right
context or whatever those things end up
as HTML elements and things don't so
it's an OK approach for for simple
things I might actually use it more now
that I've experimented with with it for
these slides a little bit more I guess
it's probably usable for some really
simple cases so let's try like another
approach instead of the angular centric
approach if you know d3 well you know
that it can do things it's actually
really good at Dom manipulation so the
first time I looked at d3 I was like
kind of confused looking at a couple of
examples because I was like this looks
like jQuery almost it's like it's got
this select function which is kind of
the first thing that you see and it's
like selecting things and I was like I
was like I thought this would to have
like a graph thing that just drew stuff
but you know it really is much lower
than that it does have data binding
right so you can you can take sets of
data and sort of get a little bit more
into that but it has really powerful
capabilities for this and sort of like
if if people are familiar with d3 like
idiomatically they want to control the
Dom right so people that create
visualizations with d3 you know they
don't want to use it on some controller
and then just put their data
like d3 like a lot of the power comes
from grabbing hold of a Dom and doing
cool stuff to so this is from on Mike
Bostock that the creator of d3 this is
an example he has a called three circles
so here so here he has an SVG selection
already he's gonna select all the
circles in there which don't actually
exist at this point this is like one of
those like head-scratching moments when
you first look at some of the tutorials
the circles don't actually exist yet so
it's selecting an empty selection and
then it does this data function which
basically takes the data you're trying
to bind compares it to that selection of
circles pretty much what happens is it
realizes that none of those data points
actually have circles yet and then when
you call it entered it gives you that
selection of things that need to enter
the Dom now right so you can also call
this exit function on there and it'll
give you sort of the things that were
not in your data set anymore but
actually we're in the Dom which is a
really cool way of doing things but very
confusing adverts especially with all
the method chaining you kind of like
never know what's being returned through
some function I'm so here's we got that
bingo selection and we append circles to
that so basically the under selection
contains four sort of phantom selections
of nothing we appended circles to that
so now we have four circles in the Dom
for each of those circles it's going to
bind well it'll just statically set 60
to there there's Center y-coordinate
it'll use this function to determine
what their export it should be right so
it's using their index so the index is 0
through 3 here times 100 plus 30 it will
set their x-coordinate to that and then
it's taking the square root of these
values for the radius so very cool so d3
can do Dom stuff and it does that data
binding right which is which is cool
okay cool um so another thing that d3
does really well are transitions
animations so that's the election right
there if I if I already have stuff in
the DOM
I guess fun entering something to the
Dom - I can call this function in the
middle of that sort of function chain
they're called transition and then
everything I do after that will sort of
happen over time which is really cool so
we're setting the attributes there I'm
at the radius center X word and y
coordinate if I called transition before
that with some sort of time all of the
attributes I said after that would have
like been tween to that value over some
sort of time so it does really cool
stuff you know that sort of transition
stuff like if you try to do any that d3
stuff and you were using just angular's
template binding to control these values
I don't even know how that would
actually work so how do we actually tie
d3 int angular them so we pretty much
decided that we want d3 to control the
Dom of its visualizations and we know an
angular all the Dom manipulation is
supposed to happen in directives pretty
much right so we'll put the d3 into the
directive right so instead of trying to
use it in a controller and just put
things on the scope for the SVG to use
we're going to do everything in the
directive we're gonna let the directive
control its old own Dom right so pretty
much the directives now are not going to
be really template based they're pretty
much just going to be using d3 to create
creative style so one way I found this
really great to actually implement the
data binding is to have those directives
have some sort of attribute on them that
allows them to get an expression from
the template so rather than
interpolating a value into the attribute
they're actually gonna tell me like in
stream value like on my model in this
place is where this data is and then my
directive is actually going to register
a watch on that specific thing instead
of having all the data again you know
interpolated into spring form into the
attribute and then pulled out so yeah
one thing I sort of glossed over was the
the thing you're sort of missing with d3
is data binding is that you know if you
saw that code you might have realized
that like that's not going to
right like those circles were created
that function ran sort of statically all
that stuff got created with those x and
y-coordinates but if that array of data
had changed like there's no because I'm
not using angular as interpolation like
nothing's gonna happen right those
circles are still gonna stay there so
pretty much you have to have in your
directive you have to sort of take
control of watching that data and then
do the appropriate d3 magic to push that
data into the visualization in the right
way so you just this is a little example
of how we would do this right so you
just gonna register or watch using the
X's like in the link function or
whatever the directive you're gonna take
the data to draw an attribute and watch
it so that anytime any of that stuff
changes you're gonna redraw right here's
a simple example this is a scatter plot
right this is all it takes to create a
scatter plot here actually I'm using a
template because I didn't want to have
anything else outside of this and
actually if you template in like an
entire SVG like the browser when you do
in or HTML will recognize that that's an
SVG and the SVG made space and so here
we're in our link function right so our
directive has been created and the scope
of it is being assigned to this link
function and it's it's sort of when this
gets called it's ready to attach to the
data so we're going to do is take the
attribute
scatter data and we're just going to
watch that expression whatever it
changes we're going to use the this is a
little bit ugly thing that I have
together but it basically just selects
this SVG you
three so now I have that selection I'm
going to do that same thing where I try
to select all the circles the circles
that aren't there but are in our data
set we'll get the Pentagon and I just
put a you know so their x-coordinate and
y-coordinate will be used to accept
these coordinates which means that my
standard a that has to be sort of an
array of objects with x and y
coordinates so here's my model I put a
series on here called test to you that's
just data points with the x and y
coordinates here's my template now so
there's no xpg in the template right now
I just have this custom directly to see
these scatter I have the scatter data
attributes where I'm telling it on my
scope and model dot test two is where
you should look for the data right so
the director of registers of watch on
this and will change any time that
changed and we get this beautiful
scatter play cool so I talked about c3 a
little bit in the design objectives so I
pretty much haven't shown you any the
actual code from c3 and I'm not really
going to in this because it's it becomes
a little bit more of a monster than
these simple examples but I will show
you kind of how it is used sort of
simple examples so first time I'm just
going to I'm gonna create a line graph
here that draws an array of numbers so
this could be a series of the concurrent
visitors on your site and for one of our
digitalization or whatever it probably
would be constantly updating if this was
an actual so here's a bit of ugliness
that exists in the current way that I'm
doing things that I'm gonna try to
remove in a later iteration but you have
to create the d3 scales on your scope
because sort of all the components that
go into this graph need to know how to
translate the data values into like
pixel values right
and the graph does control the range of
the scales so the graph knows when it's
resized and it will control the range so
it basically knows what pixel values
need to be output to actually be within
the SVG
bb-but you have to tell the domain of
your data so here I'm just setting this
so that the X domain is you know between
zero and whatever the top index is here
because I'm using the indexes will be
arranged by X and the y domain just
looks for the max value of the series so
here's the actual template I create a
graph here I'm setting the width and
height that will and the padding but
those will determine the size of the SVG
there's a little bit of like magic in
here where the padding will sort of it
uses an SVG group element to sort of
transform and shift the whole coordinate
space so there's extra space around the
edge where you can draw your axes and
stuff but so that like the scale
functions don't have to scale values and
take the padding into account right so
it just it shifts the entire coordinate
space and actually what's the Y so that
the y 0 isn't at the top it's at the
bottom we just have most of the graphs
and then this is sort of another
annoyance right now is that I have these
layers that basically just help you
stratify the different components in
your graph because SVG unlike HTML
there's no Z index so everything in an
SVG land has to be in the right order in
the DOM right things that come later in
the Dom just like statically positioned
things and HTML and things that come
later in the Dom if you're on top of
other things but because d3 is creating
everything programmatically for us and
we're not really creating it here we
create these layers and then when when
these directives sort of create the
parallel SVG structure through some
magic it it the layers so they keep
everything at the right is the order so
here's our line we're setting this line
data attribute to the series I put on
the model then I have two axioms right
so these all have like sort of smart
defaults so I just have an orientation
bottom and it knows to you
the x-axis scale orientation left I tell
it about how many texts to use again the
d3 is really smart about this I tell it
10 ticks it might actually draw heat if
like you know those would be like the
nicer values to display and then I get a
graph like this that's actually pretty
cool and there's you know it actually
listens for resizing and stuff so it's
kind of nice that you can just drop
these things into your templates bind
them to model data and then actually
just to sort of show you how the
so I basically just put a little
randomness in so there's like an
interval that's running and changing
that data on the scope you can see that
while this is running it's just every
time the data changes on the scope I
don't need to do anything the directives
are just sort of detecting that and
updating and playing and you know this
is a pretty simple directive but more
complicated ones like like scatter you
know you might have the concept of like
object identity so different things in
your data set would be matched up with
specific dots on the graph and maybe
they animate around or disappear or
appear we don't really have anything
that complicated right now and we don't
really have actually much need for that
sort of complexity right now but that's
possible so just sort of let's evaluate
this and sort of how we how we did with
our with our original goals so we wanted
to handle the common cases really easily
like line graphs and you know I think
that they're pretty easy right now right
that that seemed pretty easy you stopped
to do that sort of messy scale
management it might be nice if it sort
of it inferred the scale of things from
the data values that were set but then
that would be a little less efficient it
would have to constantly check your data
to make sure it was still on the same
bounds or whatever so some things we you
know we make a little bit more difficult
for some with some efficiency
so allowing for designers to style
that's actually super easy right now I
don't think I really need to say much
about that it's it's CSS right following
angular idioms so we're able to do
layout with templates right so that's
cool using data binding yes right so you
don't interpolate your values right into
the SVG but you sort of click your model
onto that attribute and it binds to it
playing well with the built-in
directives currently that's a fail sort
of because of the way that the
templating stuff works and that these
things sort of create all of their SVG
elements actually outside of the
original structure of that those
directives appear in putting like an NG
show and one of those things will not
hide and show the actual SVG elements
that it creates but I have some thoughts
for the next version on how that that
maybe could work so we wanted to also
allow for composability to sort of let
us take smaller bits of stuff and build
them up into more complex graphs and I
think that we pretty much succeeded with
that you know it's not super flexible
there have been certain types of graphs
that I threw together quickly for a
certain thing and then when I've we've
looked at them later I found that yeah I
basically kind of hacked it for one
purpose which is OK for now but you know
we can do better than that so next steps
for this iterator all right so we were
on c3 now we're moving to c4 things are
gonna get explosive we really want to
open source this stuff it's still like
kind of complicated I'd like to simplify
some of the stuff I'd like to make kind
of a whole you know it's it's a little
bit crazy how some of this stuff works
right now but I think it has a lot of
utility
I'd like it to make it a little bit
easier also for people who are really
comfortable with d3 to sort of have a
place like a certain custom component
that will call back one of their
functions or something
just let them take the data and draw it
you know inside some sort of context so
there are things to be done but yeah
like Harry was talking about we have
stuff that we'd like to open source
stuff no not really
I can't I can't say I really good yeah I
knew we didn't really do it shoot out
like we did for the front end of
frameworks we were more yeah guns yeah
more I mean this sort of seemed like the
thing to use it had like a really active
community and like lots of knowledge
behind it so it seemed like a safe bet
and it yeah I mean once I learned how to
use it I was completely hooked on sort
of the power of the framework the white
of u2's SVG over html5
and so you're talking about like html5
canvas yeah so canvas of like we used to
use canvas and it has a number of
disadvantages basically I mean canvas is
a pixel grid so it doesn't it's not
style with CSS right you sort of draw
things into this pixel grid and once
they're drawn there you kind of have to
like come through and erase them and
draw them again if you want to refresh
them
yeah you can't style them with CSS I
think I said that already and it's also
I mean it's you can't zoom in on it like
if people zoomed into their browsers or
when I got this like Retton on that book
it's just like oh this stuff looks kind
of fuzzy it's kind of annoying I know
you can like you can double the pixel
density and do sort of weird tricks you
can you can put multiple canvases with
transparent regions like on top of each
other if you don't want to have to
completely redraw like everything at the
same time but our our old charting
system is based on canvas and SVG just
seems like more like the future I'd like
everyone likes vector stuff I definitely
did yeah I mean it's just it's easier to
grab individual objects within the graph
right although sort of mouse hover
ability and a venting systems stuff like
that you can transform
I mean SVG has a whole lot of power that
I didn't even sort of discuss here and I
can't remember if SVG I think SVG
embedded in HTML was like part of the
html5 spec I kind of really no money
specs that well but what else
yeah so that ends up not really being an
issue the way that we're doing it
because we're not like using like a
little piecemeal templates of bits of
SVG it it never becomes an issue because
that was basically an issue with
angular's rendering engine the way that
it or compiler I think it's the compile
service that actually does this that it
just spec takes the the templates and
tries to convert them into dom elements
yeah it seems to work a little bit
differently in those two browsers I
found like a bunch of discussions online
not a bunch but a couple in like the
Google Groups by the actual angular
maintainer x' with different people
asking them to support different things
and basically it seems like it's not
really even possible to support all of
the like the things that you could do
with it because SVG elements are not
even always like unambiguously SVG like
if I had a template that just had a a
element in it like an anchor tag there's
actually an SVG element called a also
and you you wouldn't have any way of
knowing like if you just had that little
bit of template like whether you should
create an SVG anchor element or an HTML
anchor element
a Jackson set the mime type to be when
the text slash SPG
education solutions yeah so I mean all
this stuff this SPG is all being
generated within the browser on the
local data so I think you know to sort
of go to the server to do things like
that or probably not something that we
would consider
yeah
lost my little
template for the for the line graph near
the end here yeah yeah no this is
actually just directly in the HTML file
right so in the HTML file basically the
body tag is right here and then there's
just a div with this controller here so
what happens I mean I mentioned there is
like some sort of magic about the SVG
actually being generated somewhere else
so the SVG that all these things
generate is not actually in this
structure what happens is everything
that's inside of this d3 graph gets
trans cluded into like a invisible dim
somewhere else and then basically all
the stuff just exists to provide all the
scoping and stuff that you want to sort
of communicate from from your original
scope the data down below right and then
all these things talk to pretty much
this controller to figure out where the
SVG is right so do you think that trans
cluded into like an invisible Dom then
this thing creates an SVG over here and
then all these things when they do
then I keep drawing into an SPG that's
over here yeah exactly
yeah so it adds one SVG each of these
layers creates a different G element
within that SPG to sort of keep things
on the right is the index order and then
each of these components has sort of a
reference to its layer to that G element
and it draws inside there so actually it
doesn't have a template so none of these
things really have templates except this
III graph so these things that like d3
actually just creates that element right
so this c3 graph layer actually in the
pre link function gets a reference to
the SVG from the graph and just one time
creates one SVG object it's re 1 1 G
element within their right and then it
holds on to a reference to that and then
any of those final elements are able to
get from their parent controller but we
use them require to sort of communicate
between control yeah so each of these is
able to basically tell the graph that it
wants to add a layer I think maybe the
graph even added yeah the way that some
of this stuff works is not like I kind
of did all this stuff in like one quick
sprint to get like a couple graphs ready
for a new product and then like over
times like I've tried to refine some of
it but yeah I don't actually look at
that code that much but yeah this thing
creates one SVG each layer basically
tells one of the controllers to within
that SVG create another G element each
of the actual like visible components
has a reference to its layer G elements
and is able to draw ten stuff in there
so I think like like Harry was saying
you know our move to angular was pretty
nice because we were like we basically
decided to switch like when we were only
well we were actually kind of already
rewriting one of our products but we
decided it was important enough to
switch frameworks that we just like
scrapped all of that actually and
started fresh
so our publishing product was completely
rewritten in angular last year and this
was originally written to create the
graphs in that and I think so like this
graph here
and I lost some work
yeah so this rap is was kind of the
first thing that it was written for
suicide lines it has there's like its
historical line underneath the gray line
there's this screen graph that just
practic from different traffic sources
over the course of the day there's
binding to this like tooltip thing
they're events that are drawn on the
same sort of scale that these are SVG
circles that then have data that shows
up in an HTML so yes all that stuff was
written pretty much for this graph
initially which also had like a bar
graph originally and then the designer
sort of decided this stream graph thing
was better yeah what I was talking about
when I started cleaning that so we do so
if you look at
proprietary information
so here this is actually still canvas so
this is our like normal chart B product
not the publishing product this hasn't
been none of this stuff has been angular
rised yet yeah this is still this is
still based on Google closure you know
it's like I can actually do the whole so
yeah I mean how are you talk about that
a little bit too we're sort of split up
into like product vertical teams right
now people do shift from product to
product like in different in different
cycles right so we work in these six
week cycles and then after the hack week
we might reconfigure a little bit but
this is yeah maybe like two front-end
devs for projects like we've had as
little as one for certain things like
we've been stretched thin a couple times
and then we have you know data
scientists and back-end engineers
product people designers marketers all
these things or the vertical tones
one yeah good call
yeah or you can grab me after